ينضم رام الله الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
اهلا بك دكتور مصطفى تعليقك الاول على
استشهاد الاسير عدنان
اولا نحن نتقدم بكل مشاعر الفخر والاعتزاز
لعائله الشهيد البطل المناضل خضر عدنان
زوجته واطفاله ورفاقه في حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي وكل الشعب الفلسطيني وكل الاسرى
والاسيرات المناضلين الذين كانوا رفقاء له
في سنوات الاعتقال الطويله الذي جرى جريمه
وحشيه مقصوده مخططه بشكل مقصود وعن سابق
اصرار وترصد من قبل هذا المجرم الفاشي بن
جبير وحكومه اسرائيل الفاشيه التي قررت ان
يستشهد الشهيد خضر عدنان قررت اغتيال
الشهيد خضر عدنان وما جرى يجب ان يسمى كما
هو عمليه اغتيال بشعه مجرمه تجاه شخص كان
مطربا عن الطعام صحته متدهوره وتعمدوا ان
يصل الى درجه الشهاده وهذا محاوله
للانتقام من هذا المناضل للبطل الذي نجح
في السابق خمس مرات في كسر اراده الاحتلال
وانتزاع حريته من الاعتقال الاداري عبر
الاضراب عن الطعام الذي يحدث خطير جدا ليس
فقط تجاه الشهيد خضر عدنان ودعني اقول
كلمتين في حقه هذا الرجل المناضل المكافح
القائد المقدام لم يغب عن بيت اي شهيد او
شهيده فلسطينيه لم يغب عن بيت اي اسير او
اسير فلسطينيه لم يغب عن اي ميدان من
ميادين الكفاح ولذلك هذا الذي اعطى حياته
من اجل شعبه بكامله وضعها بحياته من اجل
شعبه بكامله يستحق الان من الشعب
الفلسطيني ان يخلد ذكراه بمقاومه هذا
الاحتلال وبجعل هذا الاحتلال المجرم
وحكومته الفاشيه تدفع ثمنا باهظا لما
ارتكب من جريمه وحشيه جريمه اغتيال الشيخ
عبدالرعدنان لا تقتصر على الشيخ خضر عدنان
نحن نتحدث الان في هذه اللحظه عن 106 اسرع
فلسطينيين معتقلين اعتقال اداري ولمن لا
يعرف من في العالم العربي والعالم ماذا
يعني الاعتقال الاداري يعني ان اسرائيل
تستطيع ان تحتجز الانسان لسنوات طويله في
حاله خضر عدنان لثمان سنوات دون ان توجه
له اي تهمه دون ان يعرف حتى لماذا هو
معتقل او اسير لان اسرائيل عاجزه عن ان
تجد التهم لهؤلاء المناضلين الابطال بسبب
صلابتهم واصرارهم وعزمهم وعزيمتهم هناك 13
الف عمليه اعتقال اداري جرت خلال الثمان
سنوات ثمانيه الماضيه وهناك مليون عمليه
اعتقال مليون اعتقال جرى ضد الفلسطينيين
في الاراضي المحتله منذ عام 1967
376 جثمان لاسير محتجزه الان في مقابر
الارقام وفي ثلاجات الاحتلال تصور ان هناك
13 اسير فلسطيني استشهدوا في السجون
وجثامنهم محتجز الان في ثلاجات الاحتلال
لا يوجد بلد في العالم يعصر ويحتجز ويعتقل
جثامين الشهداء الا في اسرائيل
احتجاز دون تسليم
لا
لانهم سيجروا على عمل ذلك لانه اصلا هو
غير محكوم ولكن انا براي السياسه العامه
الاسرائيليه سياسه في غايه الخطوره تجعل
كل فلسطيني هدفا للقتل والتنكيل والاعتقال
كما قلت حتى دون توجيهتهم
لانه كان هناك تحذيرات كثيره من قبل
الفصائل الفلسطينيه اذا ما حدث اي شيء
للشهيد
خضر عدنان اسرائيل لماذا تصر على عدم
اتخاذ خطوات تخفض التصعيد رغم انها تعاني
مشاكل داخليه كبيره لكنها مع ذلك سمحت
بالوصول الى هذه النهايه تفسيرك لماذا
تتخذ اسرائيل هذه السياسه
هناك ثلاثه اسباب السبب الاول ان المسؤول
المباشر عن الوضع في السجون الان هو فاشي
مجرم متطرف عنصري اسمه
انفسهم بانهم فاشيين ولا يعبئوا بذلك
والان قبل لحظات اصدر بنج فير اوامره الى
سلطات السجون بتصعيد القمع ضد الاسرى
والاسيرات هذا الرجل الماذون كسر امام
تهديد بالاضراب من قبل كل الاسرى
والاسيرات في سجون الاحتلال فاضطر ان
يتراجع عن سلسله من الاجراءات العقابيه
والان انا برايي حاول ان ينتقم من الاسرى
بعمليه اغتيال الشهيد خضر عدنان السبب
الثاني ان هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه لم
توقف عمليا تصعيدها يعني صحيح ان
الاجتياحات للاقصى تراجعت بسبب المقاومه
الباسله الفلسطينيه ولكن هم مستمرون في
عمليه الاستيطان والتهويد الان هذه
الحكومه تتحدث عن انشاء 70 مستعمره جديده
اراضي الضفه الغربيه وعن عمليه استيطان
وتوسع وضم وتهويد لكل الضفه الغربيه اذا
لا يوجد تراجع والتهدئه التي يتحدث عنها
بعض المسؤولين في الغرب هي تهدئه في ظل
استمرار عمليه الضم والتهويد وتدمير
مستقبل الشعب الفلسطيني لكن السبب الثالث
بصراحه شديده هو الصمت الصمت المريع على
الصعيد الدولي على جرائم الاحتلال وسكوتهم
على ما يجري صمت احنا 237 اسير حتى الان
استشهدوا في سجون الاحتلال ومنهم من
استشهد ايضا خلال الاضراب عن الطعام هذا
الصمت الدولي والتراجع عن محاسبه اسرائيل
على ما تقوم به من جرائم وعدم وضعها امام
القانون الدولي كما يجب ان يجري هذا هو
السبب في كل هذه الفاشيه التي نراها الان
في اسرائيل وهذه الفاشيه لن ترضع الا
بالمقاومه لن ترضع ولا تفهم اصلا الى لغه
القوه ولن ترضع الا بمقاومتها وبفرض
العقوبات والمقاطعه عليها اما الكلام
والبيانات وال
فهي لا تعني شيئا والشعب الفلسطيني فانا
اؤكد لك تصريحات الولايات المتحده
رمضان المبارك تحدثت عن وقف الاستفزازات
من كل طرف حتى لا تسوء الامور ويتم
التصعيد وكان كانت توجه تلك الرسائل
تحديدا لحكومه نتنياهو فيما يتعلق
بالمستوطنات بالاقتحامات وغيرها الحديث
الان عن المواقف الدوليه كما تقول بانها
لا ترقى لمستوى الحدث
بحجم ما يجري من اعتقال اداري هل تتوقع
بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يمكن ان
تتدخل الان وتضغط اكثر على اسرائيل
لا لا اتوقع ذلك وانا اعتقد ان هذه
الاداره اداره ضعيفه امام اسرائيل
ويعني لا تقوم بشيء فعال هل قامت باي خطوه
لوقف عمليه بناء عشر الاف وحده استيطانيه
جديده ابدا هل قامت باي خطوه لوقف عمليه
بناء 13 مستعمره اقرت جديده وبداوا
بانشائها لم تقم بشيء هل التجرا حتى على
فتح القنصليه الامريكيه في القدس كما وعدت
لم تجرؤ على ذلك هل تجرات على فتح مثلا
مكتب لمنظمه التحرير التي ما زالت تصنفها
كمنظمه ارهابيه لم تفعل ذلك لذلك انا لا
اعتقد ان هذه الاداره ستقوم باي شيء الشيء
الوحيد الذي يحرك الولايات المتحده
واوروبا والعالم شيء واحد مقاومه الشعب
الفلسطيني على الارض وعندما يدفع هؤلاء
المجرمون من بنجفير الى سموتريتش الى
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الفاشيه عندما يدفع
ثمن هذه الجريمه التي ارتكبوها سيتحرك
العالم وهذا ما سنرى من رام الله دكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام للم بادره
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه شكرا جزيلا لك